First thing's first, we noticed that both endpoints that we have are filled in.
So I'm going to need to use square brackets for my intervals to show the
inclusion of these points. Now, the point furthest to the left, in other words
the smallest x value that we have on this graph, is negative 4. So that's the
lowest value of the domain for which the function has a value. Now, moving as
far right as we can along our curve. We come to this point, whose x coordinate
is 6. So our interval goes from negative 4 to 6, including both endpoints. We
can check to make sure that our interval is right by testing a point outside of
the interval and seeing if the function has a value at that x coordinate. So
let's say, I pick negative 8. That's right here and there is no function drawn
right here. I can't tell you what the function would equal. If you asked me what
the value of the function was at negative 8, I could not give you any sort of
reasonable answer. The function is just not defined for the input. In fact it's
not defined for any input other than the x values of all the points here.